zendaya and tom holland show pda at
their first public event together since
confirming their relationship you look
really pretty and therefore i have value
no
the couple attended the ballon d'or an
annual soccer ceremony in paris making
it their first official outing since tom
confirmed their romance in an interview
with gq last month the spider-man no way
home co-stars walked the red carpet
separately but don't worry they posed
together a bunch during the event
yes that is tom's arm wrapped
confidently around zendaya's waist it's
amazing the 25 year old actress rocked a
black skin-tight vintage roberto cavalli
gown from 2000 with a gold spinal cord
replica up her back as for tom he looked
classic in a black tuxedo british vogue
posted this stunning image of the pair
on instagram grinning ear to ear it's
crazy zendaya and tom also took a pic
with polish soccer star robert
lewandowski and his wife anna tom shared
on his own instagram too check out this
video montage of his time in paris
zendaya makes an appearance and moments
from the spider-man no way home press
junket and here's tom raising a glass of
champagne to someone off camera which
could be his leading lady though fans
have speculated for years that the two
were dating things really started
heating up in july when the lovebirds
were photographed kissing in a car just
days later zendaya played coy when e.t
asked her about the viral smooch i gotta
ask you what is it like to know that you
broke the internet um that was pictures
of you and tom and people were so
excited because they're like spider-man
mj it's real like it was like the world
was rooting for this moment well i'm i'm
excited for the film to come out i can't
wait for everybody to see um spiderman
when it does come out and you know we we
all work so hard we're all so you know
we're all so close from that and um yeah
i mean i i i'm excited we're gonna have
a good press tour i think i just thought
it was cool because people were actually
rooting they were you know look the
internet can be a cynical place and it
was overall joy it seemed when those
pictures came out well thank you
in tom's cover story for gq's men of the
year issue he opened up about the
kissing picks and how he navigates his
relationship amid paparazzi and media
scrutiny he told the mag quote one of
the downsides of our fame is that
privacy isn't really in our control
anymore and a moment that you think is
between two people that love each other
very much is now a moment that is shared
with the entire world
[Music]
back in september tom posted on
instagram in honor of zendaya's 25th
birthday writing quote my mj have the
happiest of birthdays give me a call
when you're up zendaya again blushed
when e.t asked about her beau's sweet
birthday shout out very sweet post from
tom what was it like to see the post and
i noticed you commented calling now
no it's i mean i i am yeah i was it was
sweet i guess i don't know
um yeah no i um i appreciated you know
the love that i got from my loved ones
and then also from you know the world it
was i felt incredibly loved and grateful
for for all of that so you know i have
no complaints it was a great birthday
and now i'm here so
not bad and though spider-man no way
home marks the final chapter in this
installment of the superhero franchise
we can't wait to see more of this super
couple out together hopefully pj as i
like to call them has many more
wonderful adventures together
[Music]
you